this video is sponsored by - Lane
protect your passwords free for 30 days
with a link in the description when the
United States gets hungry and we do that
a lot
we like to hop in our car preferably not
get out of our car and pay an absurdly
small amount of money fast food or quick
service restaurants are a 256 billion
dollar a year business made one or two
or five dollars at a time
globally there are 20,000 KFC's 30,000
Starbucks 37,000 McDonald's and more
than any other 43,000 Subway's there's
one in every US state every u.s.
territory except American Samoa schools
churches and casinos one even was
hydraulically lifted above New York's
Freedom Tower during its construction to
accommodate workers who didn't have
enough time during their lunch break to
go down to ground level subway like many
companies got so big by outsourcing its
growth allowing just about anyone just
about anywhere to open their own
location
it's the poster child for franchising
growing 22% during the worst recession
in 75 years but it's also a perfect
example of what can go terribly wrong in
2017 subway lost over 900 US doors and
the $5 footlong the catalyst behind the
company's insane growth became the
source of its downfall so why do some
companies choose to share their business
model when they could just keep all the
profit themselves
if you a liked the idea of being your
own boss and be know how to cook you
might be tempted to start a restaurant
something like a thousand new
independent restaurants open each year
in the US and it's easy to see why the
average American spends 13% of their
income on food
nearly half of which is eating out gyms
and travel agencies are fickle but
almost everyone needs to eat and
starting a restaurant can cost as little
as a hundred thousand dollars which
while not exactly cheap is relatively
accessible for many people with loans
but of course it's much easier said than
done the idea of not having a boss
sounds great until you realize that
means working long hours getting paid
last and being responsible for every
little thing that goes wrong people
often choose to open a Mexican
restaurant because that's what they like
or a gym because they like working out
but soon find that managing a business
and eating tacos are two very distinct
skills restaurants also have extremely
high turnover and often employ family
members which makes firing them
especially difficult it's a myth that
90% of restaurants fail in the first
year but the truth is still not very
promising about 1/3 in the first year
and 2/3 after 3 although this does
include change of ownership and
sometimes owners are just ready to move
on regardless it's not an easy feat so
if you do succeed you tend to get a
little confident if you can't earn
$100,000 loan into a hundred thousand
profit in a few years why stop there a
second restaurant could double your
income at least because now you have
experience the truth is no matter how
successful you are you haven't yet
proven the business model you've proven
the business model at this location with
these employees this year breaking into
a new market isn't easy even for the
biggest companies on earth
Amazon failed in China uber in Korea and
for a long time Duncan in California a
smart business owner knows each and
every new location is a huge opportunity
and a huge risk enter the franchise it's
easy to see a company like Subway as an
stoppable Giants but one day it was just
a 17 year old kid in Connecticut trying
to pay his way through Medical School
and opening a second location meant
gambling everything the beauty of
franchising for the franchisor that is
the larger company is that it shifts
some of that risk to the franchisee the
person who pays to open a new location
and usually buys or leases the land
building and equipment every franchisee
is different but here's how it generally
works first anyone who meets the minimum
requirements can apply to open a new
location the potential franchisee and an
agent representing the franchisor will
then interview each other
deciding whether it's a good fit this
culminates in what's called the
discovery day where the candidate flies
to the company's headquarters meets its
executives and sees its operations
firsthand before making a final decision
if both parties are satisfied they sign
a franchise agreement which has three
main components first it sets the length
of the contract a franchisee is really
Elise and when it expires usually in
five to ten years both parties have to
agree to renew it otherwise the
franchisee is simply out of luck
second it outlines the costs there's an
upfront one-time franchise fee think 10
to $50,000 and an ongoing royalty say 4
to 15% of all revenue finally the
franchise agreement lays out in great
detail exact requirements for doing
business from how everything is made
what's on the menu and often what hours
it must be open
sometimes on Christmas the goal is to
maintain consistency every McDonald's
and subway and Dunkin should look smell
and feel the same without these strict
standards individual stores could coast
on the success of the brand as a whole
while cutting corners and saving money
for the franchisee this model is
attractive because it's relatively safe
if people like McDonald's fries in DC
you can pretty safely bet they'll also
like them in Portland and when the time
comes
it's much easier to sell a Pizza Hut
than a generic Bob's local pizza you
probably won't be as rich as say a
successful tech startup but you'll also
sleep much better at night knowing that
while your income ceiling is much lower
the floor is much higher
the secret to subway success is that
stability combined with low barriers to
entry its franchise fee is just $15,000
in total about a tenth of the cost to
open a McDonald's they're also quite
small just twelve hundred square feet on
average compared to McDonald's four
thousand five hundred in 2013
subway opened 50 new locations a week
that's seven every single day on average
but don't confuse subway success with
its franchisees companies like to
portray franchising as a sort of
economic marriage both which the other
success while the corporation provides
support and guidance the reality though
is often much different the local owner
of a subway for example might argue that
while he or she is in the business of
selling sandwiches subway the
corporation is really in the business of
selling its logo because it doesn't own
any of its stores but makes a minimum of
15 grand no matter how successful they
are its incentivized to open lots of
locations regardless of how qualified
the applicants unless they have
exclusive territory agreements longtime
franchisees may find themselves
competing with another subway or six
within a mile radius and they often find
franchise agreements overly restrictive
sure you don't have to come up with new
recipes or find the right equipment just
follow the instructions but you also
don't get to if you have a better idea
this tension became an all-out war with
the $5 footlong it started as a
brilliant idea something about that
clean even five-dollar price attracted
customers like nothing else in the
company's history now one would assume a
$6 footlong would sell about 20% worse
because you know math but one would also
assume no one would eat disgusting
cashews and yet you goons gobble them up
like crazy the point is people are weird
and in the 15 years since the $5
footlong was introduced haven't gotten
any less weird in fact weirder probably
but while we still like nice round
numbers because of inflation five two
thousand four dollars is now equivalent
to about six dollars and seventy eight
cents not to mention the rising cost of
labor land and health insurance which
also vary considerably by region in
other words subway is making a lot less
money
the same price well Subway franchisees
that is because remember Subway
incorporated takes a cut of revenue not
profit the promotion was great for the
corporation it even threatened to sue
other chains who used the term footlong
in advertising the length of their
sandwiches and when an Australian
teenager complained that his sandwich
was only 11 inches long
subway argued its footlong not footlong
clearly it's a descriptive name for the
product not intended to be a measurement
of length duh in 2004 subway switched to
a $6 combo with a drink and cookie or
chips but it wasn't nearly as successful
and after much fighting the company
finally made the $5 promotion optional
for franchisees in 2018 the damage it
seems was already done
subway fell into the franchise trap
focusing only on growth to the detriment
of its existing locations meanwhile
people's preferences simply moved on at
their best franchises represent the
American dream anyone with an
entrepreneurial appetite and even the
most modest savings can go from working
in a convenience store to owning one in
a matter of years but like anywhere
money is made there tend to be a few big
winners the owners of 5 10 50 locations
who've optimized for everything and many
others barely scraping by despite not
uncommonly
making a million dollars in revenue per
store each year franchising can be a
great opportunity but it's important to
remember that each new location is a new
risk not just that it will fail but
everything you own will likewise every
time you sign up for a new website or
app you risk having not just it's but
all your accounts hacked if you use the
same or similar password - lien protects
you by generating a new unique password
for each and every website and then
remembers and fills them for you so you
never have to even better you can get
the password manager and a VPN for less
than the price of each separately the
truth is no one wants to think about
security you just want to be
automatically protected and dashlane
makes it also seamless that there's
really no reason not to use the link in
the description to get a free 30-day
trial of dashlane premium and if you
like it use my code polly matter to get
10% off
thanks to dashlane into you for watching
this video